anti-semitism is on the rise in the u.s
and in fact according to the
anti-defamation league
a record number of anti-semitic
incidents occurred in the country last
year
some of the latest high-profile
incidents are reigniting a conversation
about how to stop them entertainer nick
cannon
and nfl wide receiver desean jackson
apologized after being criticized
for making anti-semitic comments and
both said they would learn more about
jewish culture and history
national correspondent arika duncan
joins us now drinking good morning
so what could they expect to learn
well good morning to you tony you know
the african-american community and the
jewish community
the relationship has been at times very
strong
sometimes contentious and even complex
so we decided to take a look back at how
we got here
and what lies ahead
this instagram post sparked an
unexpected conversation
philadelphia eagles wide receiver desean
jackson
posted a quote he attributed to adolf
hitler it read in part
jews will blackmail america i believe
that this is only through education but
all people are the same no difference as
far i'm concerned
so holocaust survivor edward mossberg
turned it into a teaching moment
the 94 year old invited jackson to visit
auschwitz
where nearly a million jews were
murdered during hitler's regime
he immediately accepted what does that
say about deshawn jackson
well i'll just say she's a gentleman
mossberg says he lost 16 relatives in
the holocaust
he now travels the world to teach people
about the horrors
he and millions of others faced how did
you survive
by luck that's all mossberg's and
jackson's story of acceptance
and learning is one that derives from a
deep and rich history
black and jewish americans have linked
arm-in-arm in their fights for equality
terence johnson is an associate
professor at georgetown
who teaches a class called blacks and
jews in america
there's something about religion and
politics that
are deeply ingrained within the
traditions both in blacks and
american jews and so when they see
themselves fighting against
say segregation jim crow or
anti-semitism in the back of their mind
they're thinking of the exodus motif
this idea that god is with them in
history
their intertwined paths brought them
together during the civil rights
movement
during what became known as freedom
summer in 1964 two jewish men and one
black man
andrew goodman michael schwerner and
james chaney were murdered in
mississippi
while trying to register black americans
to vote
their deaths and the subsequent media
coverage sparked a major change
in the portrayal of the movement america
must not remain silent
and at the historic 1963 march on
washington
it was rabbi joachim prince who spoke
just before his friend
reverend dr martin luther king jr
bigotry
and hatred are not the most urgent
problems
the most shameful and the most tragic
problem is silence
but the long-standing relationship has
turned fraud at times
with some members of both groups feeling
that their concerns
were no longer a priority for their
partners
the crown heights right of 1991 in
brooklyn saw
tensions between black and jewish
communities escalate to violence
including the murder of an australian
jewish student both groups are trying to
fight against
racism anti-semitism both are trying to
assimilate
but both are having a very difficult
time in the process and both are
actually pushed
and forced into a kind of strange and
asymmetrical relationship
but someone who believed in the power of
a good relationship
was congressman john lewis we sponsored
black jewish young leaders retreats and
congressman lewis would spend the
evening with us
helping blacks and jews sherry frank
worked side by side with congressman
lewis
on the black jewish coalition in atlanta
we marched to
mart important events we spoke out in
support of renewal and voting rights act
i see the future of black jewish
relations even strengthened by the
stress
and the polarization and the bigotry and
anti-semitism and racism that's just
flourishing in our world today
as for edward mossberg he says he will
continue until his last breath
to bring blacks and jews together does
it feel
like african-americans and jewish people
should be more connected because of
our plights not more connected they
should be
highly connected okay because we
went the jewish people went through the
slavery
in europe okay and the people here were
slavery
here by the by their own people
because it was wrong wrong wrong
wrong it was mossberg and jackson have
not visited auschwitz just yet they're
still
in the planning stage and as we reflect
on congressman john lewis this week you
know it was just last year
that he and sherry frank helped to
create the bipartisan
congressional caucus on black and jewish
relations so again his legacy living on
gail oh it's such an important story you
just told eureka and my heart just melts
with mr mossberg
such an eloquent man in the way that he
tells it i think a lot of people
should be taking the blacks and jews in
america course very very enlightening
story he invited us
to go as well mossberg invited us to go
on that trip with him and
deshawn jackson he sure did
are you going well it's up to cbs 3 good
morning i would love to go and cover
that
i think it would be great okay okay
there you go diana miller our producer
said yes you're going
oh that's great that's great thank you
very much